as your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to zinna well we're here to
tell you you're not alone itasca is the
place where muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom yeah yeah
i've got loads of male friends if
there's no attraction there then there's
they get attracted
[Music]
you believe male 1 females can only be
friends yes of course
have you ever had male friends yes has
any of them been attracted to you and
wanted to be more than friends
some but not all um do you think male
and females can only be friends nothing
more
i don't think so
um
i don't know i think it's an experience
and i
met a lot of boys
and i wanted to be friends but i just
can't okay
yes of course uh yeah
did you ever have a friend that was just
friend but he liked you
yes it happened
but
does that mean they can still be friends
it's difficult because if there is one
person that like the other one it can be
confusing after can they just be friends
nothing more
yeah
have you had ever had a experience where
you saw a guy as a friend but he wanted
to be more than friends
so if you've been through that doesn't
that show like they can't really be
friend okay do you believe male and
females can only be friends
yes
yeah i do yeah okay why
because if a girl and a girl can be
friends why can't a guy and a girl do
you believe male and females can only be
friends nothing more no they can't why
not
because once they start hanging out they
create a bond do you think male and
females can only be friends
only be friends well they can be yeah
yeah just just friends yeah just friends
yeah that's possible okay yeah yeah i've
got loads of male friends if there's no
attraction there then there's they get
attracted
do you think male 1 and females can only
be friends nothing more no
no
naturally
no
they can't no
no i believe there's always
and was that i know sorry it was a no
can i carry on there's always inside
there's always feelings there that will
make it more than friendship okay so
have you ever gone through that
experience no
are you sure no i'm joking i have yet
okay if that's the case then how could
male and females just be friends because
you've got friends but you're saying
if i had the chance i'll go out with
them
well for me i've got self-control still
so for me you know
you do feel attractive
yeah but um
others if she's my friend she's my
friend you know i mean okay have you
ever had a feeling towards a friend
that's just female but
that like
as feminists are good friends with
friends though
i can see how you can get them
okay do you believe male and females can
only be friends
yeah
have you ever had female friends
okay have you ever been attracted to
them of course yeah does that mean can
they be friends though cause you're
saying you had female friends but you
was attracted to them
do you believe a male and females can
only be friends
can only be friends
nothing else they can be friends yeah of
course they can so have you ever had
female friends
have you ever been attracted to them
yeah
so can they only be friends
do you believe male and females can only
be friends
absolutely yes
okay have you ever had female friends
yes have you ever been attracted to them
of course okay so can they still be
friends can male and female just be
friends yes definitely have you ever had
a female friend that you was attracted
to
yes does that mean can they be friends
now brothers and sisters we'll see what
the females have to say
now the males it clearly contradicts
what the females are saying completely
completely so they're like you know what
no you want me even that guy remember
that guy um
with that girl when he's like if i said
him if he had the chance would you go
out with him
he's like hell yeah of course i'll go
out with him so you know what this shows
it shows that there's a conflict of
interest here exactly and that's why
that girl walked off she's like oh my
god i can't believe what he said i think
we should go into the scientific studies
let's check out the studies and see what
the study is saying
men and women
can just be friends assuming that
they're both heterosexual in this case
appears to be not true this is
fascinating they did a study
where they brought in 88 pairs of
undergraduate opposite sex friends into
a science lab and they followed standard
protocol as far as anonymity
confidentiality etc but also got people
to agree verbally and in front of each
other that they weren't going to discuss
the study they weren't going to talk
about what they said to the researchers
amongst themselves after leaving the
testing facility
what they tested was presumably you were
just friends and they separated the the
op the men and the man and the woman
they said okay tell me do you have any
how attractive do you find your friend
to be
how attractive do you think your friend
finds you to be how interested in
pursuing a relationship with your friend
are you okay what do you think they
found
you you tell me okay the results show
that there is a huge gender difference
the women did not find on the whole the
men to be particularly attractive and
had absolutely no inkling that they
would ever have a romantic relationship
with the men however the men number one
found the women attractive number two
had a much higher estimation of how
attractive the women found them to be
and also indicated yeah i would actually
be into having a romantic relationship
with this woman so the results really
seem to indicate that men have the
harder time being just friends whereas
for women it really appears to be much
more straightforward to be just